Joan appetize new film starring Pete
Davidson has just been released on
demand which lists itself as a
semi-autobiographical film about
Davidson's life the guy is only 26 and
already has a movie about his life so I
wanted to dig a little deeper into the
king of Staten Island and find out what
in this movie is real and what is not so
buckle in because here we go
Pete Davidson plays Scott the same name
of his real-life father and to whom the
film is dedicated in the film Scott's
father was a firefighter who tragically
died when a building he was trying to
put out collapsed in real life Pete's
father was also a firefighter who died
during the September 11th attacks he was
last seen running up the stairs of the
Marriot World Trade Center before it
collapsed Pete was 7 when this happened
just like Scott's character in the film
and Scott was only seven when it
happened so Pete has also used tattoos
to remember his father and tattoos play
an important role in the film with his
character even wanting to open a tattoo
parlor restaurant website body art
guru.com has a great article outlining
the meaning of all of his tattoos which
I'll leave in the description below
including an ID card of his father his
father's initials SMD his father's
fireman's hat and the number 11 which
some have speculated stands for the date
his father died there's even a scene
where all the firefighters sing The
Wallflowers of one headlight which Pete
says was one of his father's favorite
songs
another interesting addition to the cast
with real-life connections was the
addition of Steve Buscemi as a
firefighter many of you may not know
that Buscemi was an actual New York City
firefighter from 1980 to 1984 and during
the September 11th attacks he
volunteered at his old Engine Company
digging through the rubble looking for
missing firefighters Pete's father's
death resulted in him lashing out at
school and he even considered suicide in
his youth something that is briefly
touched upon in the opening scene of the
film where his character closes his eyes
going down the freeway and nearly
crashes PETA said that the music of Kid
Cudi saved his life and if you pay close
attention both the beginning and end of
the movies start with songs from Kid
Cudi the beginning featuring a song
titled just what I am and the end
pursuit of happiness
Crohn's disease is also a significant
part of Scott's life in the film much
like it is in Pete's in his late teens
Pete was diagnosed with the disease and
used marijuana to help them through the
pain among other things the film
portrays the character of Scott as a
pothead and part of Pete's SNL persona
is that of one too and his latest
stand-up special he even talks about how
louis c.k almost got him fired from SNL
when he found him smoking pot in his
dressing room unlike the film however
real-life Pete Davidson has a history of
dating some well-known celebs including
Kate Beckinsale Margaret quale and
Ariana Grande all of these relationships
lasted relatively short and in the film
he talks about his relationship with the
character of Kelsey not working because
of his mental health there's like
something wrong with me in 2017 Pete was
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder a disorder which according to
the Mayo Clinic can include patterns of
unstable intense relationships the film
also highlights the relationship between
Scott and his mother Margie played by
Marissa Tomei both his movie and
real-life mom in real life she's called
Amy are nurses and Pete has said he's
felt guilty about his mom not dating
much because she was focused on raising
the kids and yes Pete also has a
real-life sister but unlike her being
called Claire her real-life name is
Casey fun fact Claire is played by Maude
Apatow director Judd Apatow's daughter
in preparation for writing the script
Judd Apatow spent a lot of time
interviewing Pete's family and friends
in fact Pete's actual grandpa has a
brief cameo in the film although the
character of Scott in the film is
portrayed as a lazy and lost millennial
real-life Pete was motivated and
hard-working
Pete started comedy at the age of 15 and
was quite ambitious eventually getting a
small role in Apatow strain wreck where
Bill Hader referred him to Lorne
Michaels to audition for Saturday Night
Live the film is also riddled with
personal friends of Davidson's like a
Ricky Velez who plays Oscar and the
co-writer of the film is his best friend
Dave cirrus not to mention some of the
firefighters in the firefighter scenes
are actual men and women who served
along Pete's own father
overall the king of Staten Island is
pretty true to Pete Davidson as a person
but the plot around his character is
fictionalized
as a patel was said this is a movie
about Pete Davidson if he never pursued
comedy Apatow has a history of mining
comedic talent and highlighting their
personal stories it will be interesting
to see what or who he chooses to focus
on next thanks for watching everyone be
sure to LIKE and subscribe I'm always
coming up with new and interesting
videos for more bad takes follow me on
twitter at big story whitey until next
time remember daddy loves you very much